texas is on the front lines of a fierce
battle over restrictive voting laws
and the confrontation is escalating
dozens of democrats in the state
legislature
bolted to washington d.c yesterday to
protest controversial republican efforts
to
overhaul election laws they say they'll
stay there for
weeks now governor greg abbott is
threatening arrests
ed o'keefe was at the d.c airport when
the democratic lawmakers arrived
more than 50 texas house democrats
arrived in the washington area last
night aboard a pair of private jets
after fleeing a special session of the
texas legislature
called to address about a dozen issues
including changes to state elections
laws
there is nothing special about this
special session
this is a suppression session we're not
going to put up with that
democracy is on the line the eyes of the
nation or on texas
texas democrats killed a similar
republican-backed elections bill in may
by walking out in the closing minutes of
the regular session
so governor craig abbott and republicans
are trying again
their proposals would eliminate
drive-through in 24-hour early voting
used for the first time last year
in the predominantly democratic houston
area they would also
expand early voting hours to some
medium-sized counties
add id requirements for voting by mail
and give more powers to partisan poll
watchers
last night abbott called the democrats
quitters
it's like during a football game or a
baseball game
taking their equipment when they're way
behind and just leaving the field
that is not the way that texas texans do
things
and he said they will face legal
consequences once they step back into
the state of texas
they will be arrested and brought to the
texas capitol and we will be conducting
business
to constituents who elected you
to do a job and to be in austin and
debate these issues
and they see you leaving the state today
and may think they're running away from
their responsibilities
nothing could be further from the truth
we're not going to sit in the austin
in austin in the house chamber and watch
the republican majority steamroll the
voting rights of our constituents
we're fighting back we're leaving so
they can't do that how long will you be
here in washington
well our our intention is to be out of
texas until this session is over and if
he calls another one right away
that's our message to congress we need
them to act now because they will keep
calling these sessions to pass voter
suppression legislation
voting rights legislation failed to
advance to the u.s senate last month
amid republican opposition but
bipartisan talks on the subject continue
in hopes of finding a solution
today president biden heads to
philadelphia to discuss
voting rights aides say he'll make the
moral case for why restricting the right
to vote
is a form of suppression but amid the
talks on infrastructure and other big
issues they've got to handle gail
the idea that congress would pass voting
rights legislation before the start of
their august recess
that'd be a tall order all right ed
thank you very much we'll be paying
attention